hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
the European Union passes a landmark law
Banning the input of products like beef
and coffee that are linked to
deforestation
businesses are urged to treat nature
loss with as much importance as they do
climate change or risk major
consequences for the economy
and this year's Remembrance Day poppy
goes green as it becomes plastic free
for the first time in more than a
hundred years
[Music]
foreign
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis now the European Parliament has
passed a landmark law Banning the
importation of products linked to
deforestation companies importing
Commodities like coffee soy and palm oil
will now be required to carry out due
diligence on their origins or risk
substantial fines
let's speak to our Europe correspondent
to Adam Parsons who's in Brussels for us
today Adam thanks so much for talking to
us this is a big step isn't it
it is a big step this is the European
Parliament and and I have to say voting
pretty much unanimously uh to push this
through European Union in recent years
really has tried to position itself as a
global leader in coming up with with
politically workable solutions to all
these questions around climate change
and sustainability so although this one
still has a bit of a way to go it's got
through the European Parliament has to
be approved by by all of the eu's 27
member State I think this is a
significant Landmark because what it
does is oblige companies to assure the
EU that uh no forests have been
destroyed that deforestation has not
taken place in the production of a wide
range of products I mean it goes word
coffee rubber charcoal soy beef and of
course we have seen so many times these
images of of rainforest being
destroyed on mass to make space for
these products so the company is going
to have to show that there was no
deforestation to get these things to
Market some company some countries I'd
say including Malaysia and Indonesia
have pushed but they say this is going
to really reduce their Market access I
think the EU might say well yeah exactly
that's precisely what we're going for
some smaller companies have said that
this is going to cause them problems
because they're going to struggle to
come up with all of the data and the geo
location that the EU is asking for my
feeling is that the E will say in
response this is too big a problem for
us to ignore and this has been welcomed
by a variety of organizations not least
Greenpeace
okay Adam thank you
right well some of today's other stories
now and Australia has announced new
standards for vehicle emissions to boost
the uptake of electric cars transport is
the third largest source of carbon
emissions in Australia it's estimated
the move to Greener travel could cut
those emissions by three tons by 2030
less than four percent of cars sold in
Australia last year were electric that's
compared to 17 in Europe
Tunisia has ordered its population to
ration their water usage as the country
grapples with its fifth consecutive year
of drought the lack of rainfall means
that some of tunisia's 30 dams are now
completely dry to protect water reserves
authorities are cutting Water Supplies
between 8 pm and 3 A.M until September
but there are calls for a better public
information campaign
after these procedures a booklet should
have been published explaining about
water consumption storage timing and the
quantity allowed to be stored that is
why we consider these measures
incomplete because before taking any
measure the citizen must be made aware
of the importance of conserving water
environmentally friendly poppy will be
released for this year's Remembrance Day
the historic symbol will be plastic free
and made of paper for the first time
since it was introduced 102 years ago 50
of the material will come from discarded
coffee cups with the rest made from
renewable fibers
in its living planet report last year
the WWF published The Staggering
statistic that Global Wildlife
populations have plummeted nearly 70
percent since 1970. now businesses are
being warned that they need to treat
nature loss with as much importance as
they do climate change the consulting
firm PWC says that more than half of the
global economy is either moderatory
moderately or highly dependent on nature
let's speak to will Everson who is the
sustainability director at PWC well
thank you so much for talking to us so
why do you think businesses and Industry
need to put that much importance on
nature loss
thanks for inviting me on the show
um well what our new research shows is
is how businesses are exposed to Nature
related risk and importantly what they
can do about it and what we find as you
mentioned is that over half of global
GDP that's 58 trillion dollars is
moderately or highly dependent on nature
that sectors like consumer goods food
and beverage agriculture Mining and
metals even energy generation and
distribution we also looked at Global
stock markets in the analysis and if we
take the UK for example we find that
that 47 of the market cap on the London
Stock Exchange is exposed to those same
kind of nature risks
were you surprised that in your research
it wasn't just businesses but of the 22
industries that you looked at seven of
them have a hundred percent of their
operations dependent on nature
yeah it is it is remarkable and I guess
it highlights that that extent to which
we are dependent on nature you know we
we often don't think about it but it
provides our fundamental life support
systems you know it provides the air we
breathe and the water we drink and for
businesses it provides you know all of
those critical resources from you know
uh
fiber we were just hearing about the
deforestation law you know fiber and
Timber for construction for paper but
also you know plants for genetic uh
research plants for pharmaceutical
products and it also protects firms
operations from uh you know things like
floods and it's a status code status quo
continues what are you most concerned
about
I think it is concerning and what we
looked at you know when we say
moderately or highly dependent on nature
we're saying that on on reasonable
expectations of of of ecological decline
that that value is at risk now that's
actually why today we we launched our
Center for nature positive business to
really help our clients the
organizations we work with accelerate
and nature positive and Net Zero
transition well that's mainly
fundamentally
go ahead will
I was just going to say you know
fundamentally organizations need to be
looking at how they can move from being
unintentionally nature negative to
intentionally nature positive how they
can build a nature positive strategy
what does their business model look like
in NH a positive future
so that's my next question is there
still time to get ahead of this
I think yes we're right on the cusp
right we're facing a climate crisis that
we hear a lot about through your
excellent show there's also a nature
crisis going on scientists are warning
us about the the pending ecological
collapse and and and we're right at the
cusp and I think that's the reason why
we have this you know real call to
action today
okay well thank you so much for talking
to us
thank you very much
right now before we go a reminder that
the climate Show with Tom Heap is back
this weekend and this week is a special
program on the age of climate activism
you can watch it on Saturday and Sunday
at 3 P.M and 7 30 pm
well that's all from us today thank you
so much for watching the team will be
back again tomorrow see you then
[Music]